yes hi my name is dr. Saul he am a
clinical associate professor at Stanford
Medical School and be a Palo Alto
Medical system and today we are going to
talk about this subject that have been
working for many years and that is
understanding the neurobiological basis
of cognitive dysfunction in people with
Down syndrome and try to learn from that
and see whether we can find some new
ways to improve cognitive function in
people with Down syndrome as you know
people there are three hundred and fifty
thousand people with Down syndrome just
in the United State and something like
5.6 million people with Down syndrome in
the whole world they have a duplication
of chromosome 21 and complication of
chromosome 21 leads a lot of signs and
symptoms in these individuals now if you
we go to next slide you see that they're
bouncing from actually the the
figurative Bay's have been described
many many years for many years in arts
and in history but only during the last
150 years people have paid attention in
terms of understanding the clinical
aspects and also understanding the gene
or gene that causes a cognitive
dysfunction in these individuals now as
you see this slide shows that the down
syndrome is a multi system disorder
meeting that is not just the brain is
not just the cardiovascular system they
suffer from variety and signs and
symptoms they suffer from cardiovascular
abnormalities actually that's the most
common cause of this in people with Down
syndrome more or less all of them have
cognitive dysfunction varying degrees of
cognitive dysfunction they have GI
problem they have gastrointestinal
problem and they have atlantoaxial
disability which is quite dangerous in
these individuals they have quite high
chance of seizures some of them and
indicating that this is not just a
matter of
this is a matter of many many organs in
brain of these individuals and in the
body of these individuals are affected
but then if we go little bit in details
in that what happened to them see that
their most systems it's as I mentioned
them with the systems that are affected
nervous system cardiovascular system
digestive system musculoskeletal system
but it's very interesting that maybe 50
years ago they used to only leave 23
years and then but during the last
several decades the life expectancy has
increased dramatically in people with
Down syndrome right now they easily
leave to 50s and 60s but what has
happened is that most of that has been
done because of improved surgical
methods being able to fix cardiovascular
problem is being able to find fix
digestive problems but they're not have
not there have not been much attempt
into helping them in terms of in terms
of cognitive dysfunction or find a way
to improve cognitive function or go more
fundamentally understand what are the
gene or genes on chromosome 21 that they
cause cognitive dysfunction and see
whether by finding those jeans by
shutting down those genes can be prevent
cognitive dysfunction and made landing
and memory problems in these individuals
now as I mentioned there are several
systems are affected but one of the
biggest problems also they have is that
by the time that will become they become
4d almost all of them have
neuropathological aspects of also
emergencies as you see here when they
did invent the children they have
cognitive dysfunction they have memory
problems they have disability in terms
of learning and many other aspects but
then by the time that become 40 if you
look at their brain there's no way to
distinguish between the brain of using
dividuals and a brain of an
dividual with also mantises meaning that
day brain has absolutely all the
neuropathological hallmarks that you see
in Alzheimer's disease you can see those
also in down syndrome and that's a big
deal because eventually most of them
eventually they are going to start
showing dementia of our summertime I
know a lot of people believe that
measuring dementia in people that who
have already cognitive dysfunction is
very difficult but even when you fix for
that even when you correct for that you
see that the reserve there's a problem
in terms of the moonship also my tribe
in these individuals now as I said once
you look at the brain of these
individuals you see they have lots of
amyloid plaques they have lots of them
in with their Norfleet angles they have
a degeneration of multiple brain regions
and they have brain hypo hypofunction
and there's a lot of loss of synapses
and as you know these hallmarks they
also can be found in brain of people
with Alzheimer's disease that's why
there's a very good similarities between
between the two disorders and this is
somehow good and somehow but yes it's
very bad because most of people with
down soon or eventually will show
pathology and eventually clinical
aspects of our summer disease but at the
same time is good because understanding
Down syndrome might be a clue to
understand Alzheimer disease because if
you understand what are the genes the
triplicated or what are the genes that
are causing these changes indeed let me
down syndrome we can go to all services
and then see whether we can play around
with those jeans and see where they
bring down the expression or bingo
modify the expression and see whether by
that you can modify the course of our
sub matrices and as you see there is a
good different there is a great clear
difference between the two for Down
syndrome we know the start point we know
Down syndrome is caused by duplication
of chromosome 21 we know that there are
three hundred genes sitting there and
then the gist the whole chromosome has
been sequenced and so I we clearly know
the start point but for ultimately
since we have no idea what are their
particular genes I mean a lot of genes
that have been found that they do play
major role but still we don't know
whether what particular genes inspirati
versions of awesome actresses are major
players that's why understanding Down
syndrome I would also play major role in
understanding Alzheimer disease now if
you go to next slide you see that it
shows the number of plaques and tangles
that I showed you in brain of people
with Down syndrome you see by the age of
40 there not many you don't see any
plaques and tangles but after the age of
40 you see a dramatic increase in number
of plaques and tangles which are there
neuropathological hallmarks of
non-pathological whole box of
awesomeness is in brain of people read a
Down syndrome and now now we can go to
next one now how I'm going to study that
were obviously the one of the best ways
to study down syndrome is use mouse
models most genes that are located on
chromosome 21 in human are found on
chromosome 16 that's why in order to
make a mouse model that has three copies
of most genes that are two placated in
down syndrome you have to make a mouse
that has the genes on chromosome 16
triplicated or three copies of course of
16 but unfortunately the minds that have
chrome duplication of the entire
chromosome 16 do not survive and that's
why we are using a different mouse which
is called TS 1dn this TS 1dn has a
smaller fragments of chromosome 20
columns of 16 triplicated and and this
is the most commonly used mouse model
for for Down syndrome and you see that
we have had we have used several other
mouse models that have a smaller and
smaller fragments of chromosome 21
duplicated and as you see when you
compare them and when you compare the
types among these you can identify which
portion or which segment of chromosome
16 in these mice could be linked to some
kind of phenotyping these mice and then
by playing around with these you
identify what are the genes that are
absolutely necessary to be triplicated
to cause changes in people beat and Down
syndrome now if you want to simplify the
hypothesis to say that okay we go next
you see that we want to simplify the
idea say that look there are three
hundred genes and each of those jeans
triplication of each of those jeans
causes some abnormal circuits and
abnormal circuits would those abnormal
sequence there are several brain regions
that are affected in people with Down
syndrome and those have no more secrets
lead to cognitive dysfunction it is a
very simplified way of looking at it but
then you can appreciate that there would
be two ways to treat Down syndrome one
to target the individual genes to see
okay if I identify with genius important
case I can reduce the expression of that
gene or goes a loop that is too
difficult I cannot identify the gene
then go and find up no more secrets that
are affected and see whether by
restoring the function of those abnormal
seekers you can improve cognitive
function and by doing these eight either
two ways you would have a way to improve
cognitive function in people made a
dancer now as I say the bit method that
we use is this very simple way is that
to identity the mouse model a mouse has
a tree copy of small fragments of
chromosome 16 and the reason is 16
because their genes that are sitting on
chromosome 21 on are found in mouse
chromosome 16 that's why Mouseketeer 65
DN does not have the entire chromosome
16 has a smaller fragments of chromosome
16 triplicated and once you identify a
phenotype that for instance these mice
have cognitive
dysfunction link that to a particular
gene in this mice can go and test the
effect of that particular gene in people
with Down syndrome and see what happens
if we reduce their particular expression
of that particular gene and once we
reduce the expression of that particular
gene you can see whether we can restore
cognitive function in these individuals
now then we call then may I just remind
you again that the mouse that we are
using is TS 65 DN has a small fragments
of chromosome 16 triplicated but at the
same time there are many other groups
that have made different mouse models
there is a group that they have made a
mouse model that has a duplication of
entire chromosome 21 from human they put
the entire human chromosome 21 in in in
in in mouse or there are other groups
that have it we mice that have different
chromosomes or different fragments of 16
triplicated but as I said here 65 DN so
far has been the most commonly used a
mouse model for study of Down syndrome
now if you and say ok you go and ask
what are the genes that are duplicated
in TS 65 TN mouse you see that this is
it these are the most of the genes that
are implicated and they roll you see
some of these some of the genes or cell
adhesion molecules like a PP some of
them are shattered chaperone some are
signal if signal transduction the
variety of genes that are affected in
you know that are duplicated in these
mouse models and then now by the way if
there is any question please you can ask
our question you can send all your
questions at the end of and at the end
of this session now now one area that's
significantly affected in these mice is
the hippocampus and as you know
hippocampus is a major player in
contextual learning and special learning
and obviously learning and memory in
humans and rodents now we want to study
the better there is any problem with
hippocampal region in these mice as you
see we looked at the whole hippocampus
there's not much problem
for campus but when you go and look at
dentate gyrus which is a smaller portion
or smaller sub portion of hippocampus
which is a major player in contextual
learning that area is significantly
shrunken and as you know then pajaros is
majorly made from dentate granule cells
denti ground sets are major player in
contextual learning and they receive
major projections from the hip okay from
the cortex from the internal cortex to
perform pass and as you see in this
slide that hippocampus yes it shows some
a trophy but is not much affected but
when you go and look at denta gyros
which is a major player in contextual
learning you see there is a significant
significant shrinkage as you know
contextual learning is once we combine a
spatial learning with sensory
information for instance if you find a
location of a shop the way that you find
it is that you combine all the spatial
learning in terms of navigation so where
is it located but also take some sensory
information in terms of sound and light
and presence of people when you combine
all these in your brain then you build
something like contextual learning and
this is what we think that then three
gyros which is quite affected in these
mice is a major player in contextual
learning and then obviously these mice
should show some failure in contextual
learning now if you go a little bit more
details on the components of components
of dental gyros you see this is a golgi
staining of dentate granule cells day
for instance in mouse there are a
million of these cells and each cell has
almost 5000 spines you could imagine
that only in mouse and only in one side
there are 10 billions spine and spine is
located and as you know spines are the
location that the cell is able to
communicate and make synapses with other
cells you can see that the enormous
ability of these cells to to make
enormous amount of synapses and
those contextual learning that we were
talking about now the first study for us
was that what about the status of these
cells is there anything wrong with these
cells with the dentate granule cells
which are the major major component of
dental Charles we did do the 3d
reconstruction of these cells and as you
see we have two mice here on the right
shows a tool n which is a 2 normal
chromosome and on the left is a TS 65 DN
is a try Soumik mouse model out Down
syndrome and these is this is a 3d
reconstruction of dendrites and when you
look you appreciate that there are two
problems here first their dendrites azum
are much shorter in TS 65 DN is a mouse
model of down so long but at the same
time there are four more for less
complex and then there is a reduction in
the authorization and reduction in the
complexity of the video tree in here 65
DN mouse model of a Down syndrome now
you have to understand why would II
pocampus undergoes such a degeneration
and why would the hippocampus does not
function normally in people bid a Down
syndrome or in our mouse model of Down
syndrome now we have to study this
structure and you see this is this slide
shows you that hippocampus has a very
interesting property is that mostly made
from unidirectional pathways you see the
pathways are going from dental Charles
going to c 3 and c hv to c 1 and c a
want to submit kudamon they go out but
there are two properties one is that
hippocampus is mostly made from
unidirectional pathways and to
hippocampus is a hippocampus is
innervated by some very important
subcortical regions these subcortical
regions are cholinergic cells from basal
forebrain they are histamine ergic cells
from the supra mammillary area they are
certain urge excels in raphe nuclei and
they are no repping energy cells that
coming from
soleus very importantly all these
regions and they go significant
degeneration in alzheimer disease and
also Down syndrome and then then the
other point is that all these regions if
you go to a mouse and lesion each one of
these regions you see that there is a
significant failure in concur in
cognition in this much in turn in
telling you that these regions they have
they supply with a lot of terminal so
the hippocampus and once they go down
once they don't function well the
hippocampus will suffer and the
individual or the animal would show
failure income in learning and memory
meaning that the hippocampus needs these
very important efference trees to
receive this reference to do the normal
function but today we just want to fire
going to focus on one of them and the
one that we gonna focus is the locus
coeruleus the chrysalis is an area in
the brain stem with the reason they call
it local service is a blue dot because
most cells in humans are pigmented and
these cells from local cell use they
supply norepinephrine for the
hippocampus actually these cells are the
only suppliers of norepinephrine for the
hippocampus they send major projections
to almost the entire brain and
hippocampus and it has been estimated
that for instance once and is able to
innervate pose hippocampus and
cerebellum or one cell is able to even
innervate poster both hemispheres
meaning that these cells have enormous
ability in terms of modulating the
function of the hippocampus now if you
want to study that you see the Reds are
disdaining for tyrosine hydroxylase
which an enzyme used for synthesis of
norepinephrine and you see the gold
sustaining and underwrite since saying
that you're showing the staining of
hippocampus but the bottom line is that
indeed a most cells in the hippocampus
particularly in dental Charles they
received
a lot of innovation directly and
indirectly from local service now now
going back to again locust this shows
that the start of locusts and and shows
else either get the green part and what
it shows you is that locust sends
projections to all almost there are a
few a few regions that do not receive
but almost every region in the brain
receives some kind of projections from
there from these cells and you could
imagine in humans there are 50 thousands
of these cells and in mice there are
only two thousands you could imagine
millions of millions of cells in
hippocampus and cortex received
projections receive some kind of
innovation from these cells they're just
two thousand cells meaning that what an
amazing ability of these cells to
innovate and to modulate the function of
many many other cells in the brain and
that in that indicates that is so
important and if anything goes wrong to
this goes wrong to these cells then the
animal would suffer now we said if April
if local cell use is so important let's
test that and what we did is that we
looked at you see that there are two
panels the right panel shows the
structure of locusts Lu sustained using
an antibody against titles in
hydroxylase and under on the left you
see the normal mouse as you see there is
a significant loss and shrinkage of
cells in the mouse model of Down
syndrome in local soldiers meaning that
there is a significant problem in in
this you know in this structure in in
gear 65 mouse model of Down syndrome now
if you study that in terms of roster
call down and you count these cells from
Russell to cuddle part of the locust
this is very interestingly you see the
cuddle part is more affected than
rostral part and the counterpart is the
part that sends more projections to the
hippocampus meaning that when locust is
degenerated in the TS 65 mouse model
sindrome the hippocampal region that
receives projections from this region is
the one that suffers more from other
ones now now we said okay let's study
that let's count the cells and see
whether there is any difference as you
see if you look at the age of six months
you see the white bar is the number of
cells in a normal mouse to the twin
mouse but the blue bar you see that at
the age of six there is a significant
loss of these cells in local cell use in
TS 65 mouse model of a Down syndrome but
now as I mentioned to you we have other
mice that have triplication of different
fragments of chromosome 16 if you look
at the 18 months old mice the number the
bars that have 18 under them you see the
white bar again is a normal Mouse but
then the 18 in the pink and the blue the
blue is our mouse is a TS 65 en masse
and you see that Mouse show significant
degeneration of locusts but there isn't
another mouse which is the pink part
that mouse has a smaller fragments of
crumbs of 60 inch replicated and that
Mouse doesn't show much degeneration of
locust indicating that there are portion
of crumbs of 16 that then they
triplicated they play far more road
compared with the rest of course of 16
indicating that there are particular
players their particular genes that once
they are present there they could make a
huge difference in terms of degeneration
of locust earliest one of the genes in
that fragment in TS 65 miles is a PP or
amyloid precursor protein that you know
that there is a major player in
pathology of Alzheimer's disease now if
we look at it we said okay a PP amyloid
precursor protein is it replicated in
mouse model of Down syndrome is
duplicated in down since down syndrome
also and is a player in in alzheimer
disease okay if indeed duplication of
Amalur
precursor protein protein is a player
here can be compared this much to get a
meaning that let's make a mouse model
with Down syndrome that has three copies
of a PP and then make the same Mouse but
instead of having three copies of a PP
has two copies of a PP and then compare
them and as you see in this graph we can
look at the number of cells you see the
mice that have three copies of a PP show
the generation of locals but the mice
that have two copies of a PP don't show
much degeneration indicating that
presence or absence of ATP or amyloid
precursor protein is a player in this
noise now you may wonder is that okay
you need three copies of these genes but
there are many other genes sitting on
that chromosome what about them what
about the role of them is that you know
that you need to have application of
chromosome 21 but isn't it is necessary
but it's also sufficient or not in order
to show that is sufficient or not we can
use the mouse models of Alzheimer
disease these are managed that have to
you know overexpress Swedish mutant
Mouse ap and and just a PP nothing else
I mean they don't have any other genes
implicated and you see also these mice
show that there is a significant
degeneration of locals indicating that a
PPO expression is or is just sufficient
for to cause degeneration of local
serious then so far we have shown that
local sir Lewis undergo significant
degeneration of people with Down
syndrome and then so far what we have
done is that we come to identify what
are the fragments of other the genes
that are major player in the generation
of local solution looks like one of the
change that is a major player is called
amyloid precursor protein this is now
you know so far now this is very
interesting because there is a mother if
you go and test this idea in humans and
this is a case that has been reported by
pressure at this case she had Down
syndrome she got two ages of 17
and she never showed pathology of
Alzheimer's disease and when she died
they looked at the bird brain there was
no degeneration of local soleus or no
degeneration of of cholinergic sense no
plaques no tangles even that she had
Down syndrome and very interestingly she
had replication of chromosome 21 but the
portion that contained a PP was missing
that meaning that even in humans
presence or absence of duplication of a
PP indeed is a major player in
occurrence of awesomeness pathology and
also degeneration of local service now
now we go to now what we wanted to do is
that ok if this is the case you know we
know that they're there is a
degeneration of dissipation of local
serious but what happens to terminals of
locusts alleles from local circles in
the hippocampus that's why we used a V
Matt which is a marker for terminals of
local cell using the hippocampus as you
see a normal mouse in twin on left it is
a quite a good expression of these you
know this market but when you go and
look at the right side you see there's
quite a flattening meaning that there is
a significant loss of terminals coming
from local soleus to the hippocampus
this is all all these shows now if you
if indeed focusing on the go significant
degeneration and if indeed there is a
loss of these terminals what happens to
the level of norepinephrine in aleppo
campus and also molecules that become
activated by release of norepinephrine
we measured norepinephrine in these mice
there was a significant reduction in the
level of norepinephrine these mice here
in this picture shows that the micro
punch just the dentate gyrus a majority
of dental gyros and measure exactly
Campion as you know when norepinephrine
binds to its receptor is beta 1 and beta
2 induce a cyclic AMP deformation and
what we see here that there is a
significant reduction in cyclic A&P
production in ta-65 mouse model all down
syndrome indicating that yes there is a
loss of terminals there is a loss of
amount of norepinephrine and also there
is a loss of second messengers because
of lack of presence of norepinephrine in
these mice now we can we can summarize
what we have is that so far we know that
locus is a undergoing degeneration we
know that presence or absence of a PP is
a major a major player and now we have
to see ok we have a phenotype what is
the phenotype phenotype is degeneration
of local cell use in the t65 mouse model
of Down syndrome now we try to link that
to a gene which was a PP now the next
next task is that can we fix that is
there any way to fix them obviously if
you think what is the role of new local
so loose they make norepinephrine then
simply we can put noda preferring the
brain and or inject some norepinephrine
and try to try to see whether you can
restore restore that but let me show you
what's the problem they're the this is
chose two compartment one shows the cns
one shows the periphery and obviously
there is a border the barrier in between
which is called blood-brain barrier
there are two problems with a strategy
of using norepinephrine one is that
norepinephrine does not cross the
blood-brain barrier and that's one
problem to e even if it crosses the DPP
you bail out brain barrier and it goes
to the cns but it's still there are a
lot of receptors for norepinephrine
inner periphery on hard on
cardiovascular system on the respiratory
system that's why in this case in our
minds they're going to suffer from all
these signs and symptoms because of
increased norepinephrine now we have to
fix that the Vader we try to fix that
eat instead of using norepinephrine we
use the precursor for not appearing
called el ducks elders is an old truck
has been made almost nine years ago in
japan
this drug is a prodrug for
norepinephrine when we inject it into
mouth and using a dbh enzyme is able to
be converted into North nothing the good
news is that L dubs very easily cross
the BBB gets to the brain but then in
order to prevent the private payroll
effects of l dubs what we did at the
same time that we used elders views
carbidopa and carbidopa is an enzyme it
is actually is it is there factor that
prove inhibits TBH meaning that prevents
the conversion of l dogs into
norepinephrine that's fine but the good
news is that carbidopa can not cross the
PPP what does this mean it means that
conversion of L dubs to norepinephrine
only happens inside the brain not
outside why because carbidopa cannot
cross the BBB that's why the other side
it get elapsed easily converted to
norepinephrine but in the periphery
because of presence of carbon oppa and
then there is an inhibition of dbh now
now we kind of fix the problem because
we say okay we have a factor which is l
dobbs easily cross st BBB and easily
converts into norepinephrine and we can
prevent the peripheral peripheral
effects of this drug now let's see
whether we can fix that and this graph
shows just you I think for the sake of
time you just have to look at the lowest
at the lowest panel by blue and ya blue
and white channel every bug bars and as
you see what we measured here is
something called contextual learning and
contextual learning is measured by
putting a mouse into a small chamber a
lead a bit of tiny amount of shot goes
to his feet and then the mouse links the
shock to a context which is the room and
then the shape and all these factors and
get TS 65 miles did you want and then
what you do you teach the amounts that
oh if you go to this room you're going
to get shocked a tiny amounts of beer
million products shocked and then he
remembers that but the day after when
you put the mouse back into that room he
remembers that Oh display
is the one that I was shocked that's why
he's going to freeze and what we do we
have a software that you are a is able
to quantify the amount of freezing in
these mice and once we freeze once we
measure that freezing we say Oh whether
the mouse remembers or not because if
the mouse forgets that is not going to
freeze but the minds that do not forget
are the ones that freeze more as you see
the normal mouse and tears 65 normal my
squad remember very well dear 65 mouse
model of Down syndrome do not remember
you see their low then the lowest panel
shows that the lowest panel there are
four bars the ones under on the left
side are the ones that are not treated
you see that there is a significant
difference between the TS 665 mouse
model of Down syndrome and normals but
once you give these mice a combination
of L dubs and carbidopa there is a
complete restoration of contextual
learning in these mice now one of the
other we have tried to use multiple
modalities to measure a cognition in
mice one of the other ways which is very
simple called nesting mice have a
natural ability to do nesting we give
them a little bit nest let and what they
do they make an fluffy desolate and
nesting and injustice sleep sleeping it
but they do that very well when you move
them to a new environment you can you
can encourage that by moving them to
very easy to a new environment and as
soon as they pay attention to the new
environment it can do a goodness what it
looks like is that you see the dead the
green chuck greenberg green net dots or
green signs show that the normal mice
they always make pretty goodness nest
bear nesting but their red dots are the
ones are the from mouse model of down
soon of the t65 months they don't make
much nesslun they don't use that once
you give them the drug you see that they
can make a pretty goodness nesting once
you stop that they go back and we use
that as an indication of a potential why
is that because once the normal Mouse
pays attention that the cage has changed
they are more encouraged to make
clean but with the TS 65 miles
molybdenum does not pay attention much
to the environment and because of that
they are not much encouraged to make an
exit and it's very interesting they have
the natural ability to make nessa is not
the fact that they cannot make nests let
the fact that they can use it but
obviously they don't pay much attention
to be able to to do to do it here now
now once mr. wendal you know a few years
ago when we started this process the
dell dumps was not approved by the fda
but the good news is that the drug was
just approved by the fda but then we
wanted to do okay we wanted to expedite
the process of drug delivery and drop
finding that's why we said okay is there
any drug right now in the market that
could do the same job that held up state
where and as you know norepinephrine
binds to a variety of receptors to a
presynaptic alpha receptors and [ __ ]
nap takes beta on beta 2 and beta 3
receptors but then if we wanted to loop
we said okay can we study agonist of
these beta receptors there beta 3
receptors not not much better three
reasons are in the brain but beta 1 and
beta 2 beta 1 receptors in the periphery
are found on the cardiovascular system
and as you I told you the most common
cause of this in people with Down
syndrome is cardiovascular program
that's why you can you should avoid
using beta 1 receptors better one
receptor cyclist but one idea is that
what about using beta 2 receptors that
in the periphery most of them are found
in in respiratory system this picture
shows beta 2 receptors in dentate ground
all sorts of the hippocampus and their
colocalization with synapses meaning
that they do they are present there and
they are in the right area of now you
see again shows the picture say where
are they located in dentate granule
cells under student the ground ourselves
have express a lot of beta 2 receptors
now before start before using it at any
beta2 agonist we have we wanted to know
whether what about the expression of
beta 2 receptors in the hippocampus
dental choice of these mice and as you
see it shows the frequency distribution
of beta 2 receptors in normal than TS
sixty five months and actually shows
that not only there is no no reduction
or beta today's actually the bit
increased levels of beta 2 and this
could be some kind of compensatory
increase beta 2 expression in April
campus and telling you that look the
machinery of the machinery of beta 2
signaling is activate is active in these
in these mice then now what we were
worried is that if you give them a drug
for instance we found a drug called for
module this is a drug that used for
treatment of asthma for many years
approved by the FDA at in United States
for a long time and we wanted to see
this drug this drug is a long-acting
beta 2 agonist and we wanted to see
whether if you use that drug can we by
improving beta 2 signaling improve
cognition but what we were worried was
the peripheral effects because we're
worried about a peripheral affixed what
we did we said we use a beta antagonist
that does not cross the ppt and be used
not alone and then for for all mice we
use the combination of natural or wheat
for module now the load is a beta 1 and
2 antigonish that Club does not cross
the BBB but for Motorola is a beta2
agonist that you know some of it crosses
typically and then we wanted to measure
the peripheral effect we measured the
respiratory rate and blood oxygenation
in these mice and as you see when we
treat them with our agonies does not
have any peripheral effects in these
mice and this is meaning that at this
peripheral is quite safe now what we did
here is that we use a test called the
open field open field test has been used
by many people as a as a one indicator
of you know cognition because usually
transgenic mouse models of Down syndrome
and alzheimer disease they are quite
hyperactive their velocity is high and
total distance that they go to this
simple you know bear simple square a
square box and
as you see here there is a significant
hyperactivity in these mice but once you
treat them bit from a sword there is a
significant reduction in open field
activity and and reduction the severity
of hyperactivity in this mice which is
indicating it's at least is working and
you measure that across the different
minutes you see that on the on the left
panel shows that there is a big
difference between dead is 65 DN and 2n
but when you go on the right side
there's not much different meaning that
we were able to significantly improve
context you improve an open field
activity in this must be also measured
we also measured what we did we measured
the contextual learning we put them into
fear conditioning and we found that
indeed when we treat that we can
significantly improve contextual
learning in these mice now there once we
did that once you realize that drug is
improving contextual learning is
reducing hyperactivity in open field
open field does it do anything
postmortem that's why you psyched this
mice and we counted the number of
synapses in the dentate gyrus of these
minds as you see on the left side shows
there is a significant reduction in the
number of synapses in the t65 mice but
when you treat them bit for motorola
which is a beta2 agonist there is a
significant improvement and increasing
the number of synapses into in 65 years
now what about activity can we increase
number of cells that are become active
after contextual learning and before in
order to do test that we use the Cephas
Cephas is immediate early gene that
becomes activated when the mouse goes to
this fear conditioning and learn
something and you see the difference
between twin normal orbit when that got
not alone there's a significant
reduction in tier 65 month but once you
treat the t65 miles which formoterol
beta2 agonist you see there's a
significant increase in the activity of
cells or the number of cells that become
activated after contextual
learning in TS sixty five months now we
measure that you see that you quantify
that you see there is a significant
decrease in 365 miles but once you treat
them bit for much work you can restore
that and then restoration and that
increased activity is not just matter of
one region throughout the entire
hippocampus this increased activity
happening meaning that more cells become
active after you know after using for
module and after going through the
process of contextual learning now now
the next step is that to understand how
does this work what is the role of beta
to obviously be no beta 2 receptors we
know for mutual points 2 beta 2
receptors induces LTP but what other
what other effects beta 2 receptors
would have one of the ideas that have
been lot of people have been working on
neurogenesis is that this is it after
you know the mouse is born and there is
some minor neurogenesis in dentate gyrus
then the ground ourselves you see these
cells are born and then usually micra
throughout can't aground a cell layer we
wanted to know whether the when we treat
our minds wait for ma troll can we
target then take granule cell you know
the new cells that are born but one
marker people use different markers but
we used a double coating which is a
market for cells that eventually are
becoming neurons either they die or
become no loss and then we wanted to
test them we use that but we realize
that the drug is not able to increase
their number but what it does it
increases in complexity you get here see
the next image shows that it measures
the complexity of dendritic arborization
in New in double curtain stained cells
you see that on the right panel you
quantify these order arborization the
first organization won the second
organization to and then these are
different levels of arborization but
then you average the levels of
arborization between TS and when you see
that there is a significant reduction in
complexity in 65 miles but once you
treat them we do it for module this
significant increase in complexity of
dendritic formation meaning that somehow
beta2 agonist is able to help these
cells the newly born cells to make
better connections and perhaps make
better synapses and more synapses weed
everyday environment and then if you
quantify that to quantify the
arborization see one shows these are
both from the s65 mouse model but on the
right panel easton is is treated before
module and the left manner is not
treated before module you see that you
can increase significantly the
complexity and lens of these fibers in
in after the treatment before motor
indicating that somehow is improving
these cells in terms of their
communication now we also looked at
others or other cells let's say in terms
of asteroid is the gfap staining we did
we found more gfap staining in 265 miles
but we did not find much effects of the
drug but what they what we found very
interestingly we found the migration of
these cells increasing this cell shows
their distance to location of these
asteroids throughout dental Charles and
where are they located you see the ones
that are treated with formoterol the
more migrated towards outside compare
with another load triggered just
suggesting that maybe what formoterol
does is also increasing them my great
migration of astrocytes in these mice
now let's go back and then their review
what we have as I say there is a
degeneration of hippocampus happening in
disease is in these mines and they are
innervated by local sara luis and
there's a significant degeneration of
local soils in these mice and you know
and then looks like by restoring the
function of local sailors you can
significantly improve improve contextual
learning in these mice and this shows
that the way that these that innovation
coming from the cortex to see then
innovation coming from and turner cortex
they carry both sensory and
a sensory information and spatial
information coming to the day identity I
rose and once today will they come
together these cells the dent Agarn
cells take that integrate that both
sensory and spatial information together
and build contextual learning now now
one one aspect that has been recently
paid attention is that look increasing
norepinephrine signaling can indeed
improve cognitive function but also
could have some role on ad pathology on
awesomest pathology for instance look at
these mice these are the mouse models of
our summer disease but it's very
interesting if you for instance if this
is a just a simple mouse and the mouse
model of dancing at mouse model awesome
a disease what you do is that once you
lesion locus you can significantly
reduce norepinephrine that's very simple
but when you give them L dubs you can
restore the level of norepinephrine back
in these mice but then if you look at
the next figure this is very important
this is shows the brain I'll hippocampus
of a mouse model of alzheimer's disease
these mice have shown a lot of a beta
pathology in the hippocampus they
daddies has been shown by many people
that's not new but what is new is that
once you lesion loko sir Lewis once you
reduce the level of norepinephrine the
hippocampus of these mice they're going
to have more accumulation of a better
meaning that somehow somehow
norepinephrine is also able to modulate
how much Lucas how much a beta is
accumulated in these in these mice and
then it's very interestingly meaning
that if you put Nora profit in the brain
of these mice what's happening is that
it activates microglia and these micro
get activated microglia it has been
hypothesized that they go around flags
and what they do they encircle plaques
and then kind of clear lead out meaning
that once you add norepinephrine it
could have two functions one function
synaptically improves cognition improve
synaptic function include improves LTP
but the extra synaptically what it does
it activates
microglia and once you activate
microglia metrically a move move more
toward flex and they eat in the elevator
you know plaques and clear increase
their increase their clearance of a data
from the brain of mouse models of of
Alzheimer's disease anyway there then
this is a simply simple this is you just
put the whole ideas of hypothesis
together you say that we have three
application of chromosome 21 because of
some unknown factor for instance failure
and trophic factor signaling that leads
to degeneration of locusts ol news the
locals goes down norepinephrine goes
down norepinephrine goes down that leads
to cognitive dysfunction very simple but
once you once now this is what we did we
a we gave beta 2 agonies and that
increased in norepinephrine signaling
one way increases some trophic factors
and that increased increased dendritic
arborization increased synapses and
improve contextual learning but at the
same time extra synaptically but it does
increases microglial activation and
because of that increases a better
clearance and hopefully that would also
improve cognitive function and these are
the members are my lab and our
collaborators and thank you very much I
think there are questions that we can
there are a few questions that i'm going
to read given the importance of mouse
models why aren't you using mouse
developed by yes i mean those mouse
models are just recently becoming
available and these mice 3065 might have
been used for many many years and we
have a pretty good idea about the
pathology but so far i've been seen from
other groups and we have not learned
anything extra from those mice but they
do those much just becoming just
becoming available to other groups now
the next question is that i thank you
for the presentation are you saying we
can link down syndrome with Alzheimer's
have there been as
have there been substances I don't see
oh thank you for the presentation are
you saying that we can link down
syndrome and alzheimer disease yes yes
days are very clear there is a very
clear link between Alzheimer's disease
on and Down syndrome as I said everybody
after the age of 40 with Down syndrome
will show pathology of Alzheimer's
disease and eventually the majority of
them will show dementia of our cemetery
now have there been substances that have
been used since in use downstream in
mice because in area a tree there are no
engineered mice have there been
substances that have been used to induce
no no that the way that these mice have
been made the mouse models of Down
syndrome are made by radiation and
during the early phases of embryogenesis
that's why I don't think that's the way
and then have there been report on
electrical activity in the brain of Down
syndrome children yes certainly i mean
it certainly there is a lot of there's a
lot of a lot of research on on the
abnormal electrical activity and you
know electrical activity in the brain of
people with Down syndrome now the next
question is it really a lot loss of
locusts earliest known that is observing
365 mountain or overall the generation
of the brain or certainly is overall the
generation of the brain bodies but this
area is far more affected than others I
mean yes there are other areas that are
affected in people with Down syndrome
and mouse models of a Down syndrome we
have studied cells in search for
instance in cholinergic cells we have
studied cholinergic sense we have
studied the histamine ergic cells we
have studied serotonergic sets but looks
like this area is
very much affected in those people with
a Down syndrome and alzheimer disease
and quite early there is a new study
from Bragg showing that actually even in
healthy individuals these mice these
cells cells in local soldiers are
reduced shows significant degeneration
even in healthy individuals at the age
of six years meaning that there is
something wrong with you know with these
cells very early yes certainly locust is
not the only region that is affected in
people with Down syndrome but it's a
major region now are the genetic
duplication of a PP corrected with the
RNA or protein over-expression yester a
lot of I mean we have also we have done
a lot of experiment to see whether by by
drugs that are able to bind to a PP
reduce the expression of a reduced
expression of a PP and that's right now
ongoing and I guess that would be one of
the ways to to fundamentally treated
tree did some some aspects of Down
syndrome is is in your mouse model is
the increase or decrease in dopaminergic
innovation of the hippocampus
accompanying the loss of norepinephrine
yeah but as you know there is not much
innovation of the hippocampus by
dopaminergic terminals and other than
that I don't know but I know that people
can put generally does not receive much
German much to Palm energy criminals but
besides we did not study that they're
all but i know in mouse models of all
cemeteries disease there are couple of
studies showing that there is abnormal
dopaminergic activity and dopaminergic
levels in the hippocampus but not in our
mice are these pathological observation
translated into human yes certainly
people with the people with Down
syndrome people with Alzheimer's disease
shows significant degeneration of locus
coeruleus quite early that's why what we
find here is very well related to what
we find in people we'd both Alzheimer
disease and Down syndrome are there any
side effects of this therapy absolutely
there is no no drugs no
therapy but you know that's why right
now we are trying to reduce the dose but
playing playing around with the doors we
are very worried about the side effects
in terms of peripheral effects that's
why we have to we are working to see
whether there's any way to reduce the
side effects but but there is it but the
absolutely there is no drug ever that
has no side effects but we have to have
some kind of balance in terms of
positive and negative effects of of the
truck and then the next question what is
the genetic background in 365 a mouse
model these are these are made
commercially available by ejection and
these are I think there are seats III HB
six and then thank you for the
presentation the increase a PP needs to
increase a beta tool that causes Down
syndrome same as a teen not necessarily
because people massed models of Down
syndrome they have only three copies of
a PP and we did not find much a data in
these mice and as you know even in
alzheimer disease by increasing a PP a
little bit you won't be able to make
much a better you have two over X a PP
much and version of a PP multiple
multiple time to be able to to make a
better that's why I think the problem
here in our minds is more a PP rather
than a data now follow up on dr. you
fully tries to make for all humans from
21 the doctor you fully try something
for all human 21 synthetic region mouse
commercially available will you try to
replicate your findings in this myself I
don't think they are commercially
available yet but hopefully they will
become available but as soon as they
become commercially available we will be
we would love to tested on those mice
because I do think they would replicate
at least genetically I don't know about
in terms of signs and symptoms but
genetically they would replicate better
Down syndrome compared with pier sixty
five months now how does come you called
yopo aid inactivation of inactivation of
L dumps to the brain only rather than
Oh carbidopa oh how does carbidopa yes
carbidopa is a factor that inhibits ADH
is an enzyme dbh in order to convert l
docks to norepinephrine you need an
enzyme that enzyme is inhibited by
carbidopa that's why once you give held
up together with carbidopa carbidopa
would not let any l dubs be converted
into norepinephrine but carbidopa once
we injected I you know I p or
subcutaneously does not cross the BBB
meaning that inside the brain there is l
dot there is nothing else converted into
norepinephrine in the periphery there is
the bell dubs but it's also carbidopa
sitting here which would not let to be
converted back into converted into
norepinephrine Thank You excellent
presentation and woke oh thank you very
much for four persons if there's any
other questions please I think you have
my email and you can ask and you can
send me SME questions thank you so much